good evening to you tonight we're
learning a bit more about the death of
former zappos ceo and downtown las vegas
supporter tony shea
thank you so much for joining us at five
i'm brian loftis
hi there brian and i'm denise valdez we
can tell you that shea died
friday more than a week after he was
injured in a house fire a little earlier
this month
which happened in new london connecticut
now he's known of course for helping
revitalize downtown las vegas
shea invested 350 million dollars in
real estate entertainment and tech
startups in the area
and he was crucial in developing
container park and some of the famous
art installations we know and love
in downtown las vegas the i-team's david
charns joining us now
live near downtown with new details
tonight david
well denise tony shane meant so much to
downtown
and his former colleagues here outside
of zappos we're learning that he died
from smoke inhalation
in that fire and radio calls between
firefighters are helping to piece part
of this puzzle together
it's going to be an actual status that's
attached
to the exterior of the house and the the
mail is there
he's not answering the door we have one
victim
being pulled from the fire now
unresponsive
now it's not clear if shea was
barricaded in the shed as radio
transmission you just heard indicate
or if he was somehow stuck inside that
area appears to be attached to a guest
suite in that home's basement it has its
own kitchen
fire officials telling the i-team today
they had to actually force their way
into that home to pull shae out and that
others in the house were able to escape
the i-team also confirming the home is
owned by rachel brown a long time zappos
employee
records show brown bought that house
just this past summer
now video from in front of the house
monday shows no visible damage there's
also a car in the driveway there
right now it's unclear how the fire
started or how shea became trapped
inside that storage area now we have
reached out to brown we have not heard
back
i also heard from the coroner coroner in
connecticut today
who tells me that this death has been
ruled accidental but they are waiting
for some more tests to come back
before they sign the death certificate
live outside zappos downtown i'm david
charns 8 news now